let's talk about what's happening in sri
lanka
[Applause]
[Music]
the country has run out of money and the
economy is in free fall there are
shortages of food
fuel
and medicine the currency has crashed
and prices for everything are sky-high
and a lot of sri lankans blame the
government and president gotabaya
rajapaksa
there have been weeks of protests across
the country the prime minister mahinda
rajapaksa who's the president's brother
has quit
and things have gotten pretty violent
government supporters stormed the main
protest camp in colombo
almost about 20 20 000 came with six
heavy sticks and they beat all of us
anti-government protesters set fire to
the homes of some ruling party officials
and stormed the prime minister's
compound he had to be rescued by the
army several people have been killed and
hundreds have been wounded it's a
economic crisis that was brought on by a
political crisis and now we're just
generally in crisis so why are so many
sri lankans fed up with the rajapaksa
family what's gone wrong with the
economy
and what's it going to take for sri
lanka to get out of this mess
[Music]
let's start with the rajapaksas they're
a family dynasty who've dominated sri
lankan politics for nearly 20 years
they've been accused of nepotism
corruption and being bad administrators
mahinda rajapaksa served two terms as
president and gave dozens of family
members government jobs there was a new
president in 2015 from an opposing party
and then four years later mahinda's
younger brother gautabaya rajapaksa was
elected president he made mahinda prime
minister and handed out a bunch of other
jobs to relatives we had the sauna
sports minister we had you know the
other brother the nephew the you can
just go on and on and the
daughter-in-law's mother and cousins etc
were all appointed to different
positions and it became a family
business so sri lanka though it has
followed the electoral democratic
process
and everyone who is in parliament and
the president has been elected
has also the features of a family-run
state
and and sort of authoritarian uh
structures and when it comes to the
economy both mahinda and gotabaya
rajapaksa are accused of messing things
up pretty badly for a long time the
government has been spending more than
it takes in and sri lanka also imports
more than it exports that means it's
been using up more foreign currency than
it's earning now a lot of countries do
this and they borrow money to make up
the shortfalls that's not necessarily a
problem it's actually pretty normal for
any modern economy but in sri lanka's
case the debts have become unmanageable
the government's basically run out of
money
think of it like having a huge credit
card bill and getting to the point where
you can't pay the minimum balance each
month
for sri lanka that's the seven billion
dollars due this year in april the
government defaulted on its loans
admitting it can't make the debt
payments anymore
our reserves kept coming down until the
reserves came to zero
and the situation exploded
to the current crisis that we have now
there's not even enough foreign currency
left to pay for the imports of essential
goods and it's led to terrible shortages
and long lines for things like cooking
gas
people are now
starving
in short supply you don't really know
what holes for people tomorrow so why
are so many people blaming the
rajapaksas for all of this
well there are a few big reasons why the
situation got so bad when mahinda
rajapaksa was president he started
spending big time on huge infrastructure
projects some of which ended up being
duds like the lotus tower on which we
spent 400 million rupees which is not
being used at all and getting into debt
for these projects we've also had
massive corruption uh so it is a
cumulative thing cricket stadiums uh and
even port expansions that took place
uh didn't have a return that justified
their investment so years of this kind
of high spending and high borrowing was
already storing up problems for the
future and then when the current
president gotabaya rajapaksa came to
power in 2019
he made a couple of drastic decisions
that totally derailed the economy first
he followed through on his election
promise to bring in huge tax cuts but
those cuts meant the government suddenly
lost out on a lot of money about 25 of
its revenue the government stated that
the reason is that they were going to
give more incentives to people to
businesses to earn more and then develop
the economy and provide employment but
also the reason was that they were
facing a general election after the
presidential election a few months later
this was not something that was advised
it was not based on expert advice or
research it was a populist move the
other thing gotabaya rajapaksa did was
to force sri lanka's farmers to go
completely organic pretty much overnight
the government banned the use and import
of all chemical fertilizers no country
in the world goes into organic farming
100
at best developed countries like germany
have maybe 10 to 15 organic farming and
it was disastrous for sri lanka's
farmers who were suddenly producing much
less
it got so bad that sri lanka had to
start importing rice something it never
had to do before and food prices went
way up what it did was cause an
escalation in prices in the local market
for stable foods
that people were accustomed to getting
easily and cheaply and remember while
all this was going on over the last
couple of years there was also the
pandemic and all the problems that
caused the tourism industry took a
massive hit and tourism is usually one
of sri lanka's biggest earners and an
important source of foreign currency
so basically by the middle of last year
all of these problems were coming to a
head and it was already clear what kind
of financial trouble the country was in
but the government didn't really face up
to it analysts say the government is
like an ostrich with its head in the
sand not taking corrective action was
the huge governance and policy mistake
that was made i think which caused the
crash to be so much more severe than it
could have been so what happens now
well on the economic front sri lanka
desperately needs cash india has offered
up more money to help with fuel imports
china has also put more loans on the
table but the main hope is to secure a
big bailout from the imf
talks have started but a deal is still
months away at best these negotiations
have a lot of technical uh hoops to jump
over sri lanka really does have to show
that there is a legitimate stable
government that is able to
deliver on the undertakings given to the
imf and the creditors and that's a whole
other challenge because things really
aren't looking too stable on the
political front
president rajapaksa has now appointed a
new prime minister ranil gramasinghe
he's from an opposition party and has
had the job five times before
the idea is that he'll head up a new
unity government i.e one that brings
together lots of different political
parties to try to find a way out of the
crisis but so far the main opposition
parties are refusing to get on board
they want what the protesters want for
gotabaya to go
whatever happens the longer it all drags
out the more painful it's going to get
for the sri lankan people
some of those big infrastructure
projects that we talked about were
actually backed by china part of a mega
project known as the belt and road
initiative we've got an episode on that
which you can watch here
[Music]
you